Sanibel Island on Florida's southwest
coast has been cut off from the mainland
there's just one way on and off and that
causeway is closed to Kris Van Cleave
made it across this morning Chris good
morning good morning they are starting
to inspect that causeway what we're
finding here on Sanibel Island a lot of
this giant trees that have come down
they've taken down power lines and
places where the trees are still
standing there's water on the roads it's
making it very hard for first responders
to get into all of the neighborhoods and
assess the damage there are simply
places here you can't go to and let
unless you have a buzzsaw now here's
what we know about Fort Meyers damage
assessments are underway there they were
able to get their first responders back
out overnight to check critical
infrastructure and now they're gonna go
block by block looking for damage power
is out not only here on Sanibel but
through most of Lee County so people are
gonna be in the dark and that could be
that way for days that could begin to be
an issue when it heats back up here
tomorrow but right now we're not hearing
reports of catastrophic damage in fort
myers proper and the sense is while
there is still a potential for storm
surge with high tide this morning that
it has not been as bad as feared as
feared now remember how 30-thousand
people went into evacuation shelters
because there was the potential for a
10-foot storm surge or more we are
starting to see some of those shelters
clear out now that there the curfew has
lifted as of 7:00 a.m. people are going
to get back on the roads and start
looking at what their homes look like
police are asking people if they can
wait a little bit longer that would be
ideal because they're still really
trying to get a sense for what roads are
safe and there are a lot of downed power
lines some of those are active Nora
really good report there Chris thank you
so much